to get the adrenaline Arc in Tech you
need something that will be disruptive
and will get to mega growth
okay this has the now the potential of
that mega growth and that's why I'm
spending you know my energy there and
the results
are starting to come in so the
adrenaline is flowing
and then you know that's uh that's like
uh the best feeling in the world because
it gets you you're addicted to it
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctec
I I appreciate very much your time and
for
um you know spending this time with me
you are such an interesting you know
Persona in the tech ecosystem the
different things that you've done are
quite quite remarkable from being a
president
of a division within mdocs to Chief
business officer at our media radcom
Celine Dion today with a with the
amazing investment arms behind you I'm
really excited to unfold your journey in
your story in the communication space I
obviously know how meaningful the space
is for my own experience especially in
the from a from a cyber perspective but
I'm excited to understand what it means
to to to be in the space today and so
thank you again for being here your own
tell me a little bit about your
connection to the space what got you in
here and what hooked you that this is
going to be the the the the vertical
that you're going to be spending most of
your time on
so you know from
him I'm an Industrial Engineer by
profession okay so I think keyword is
engineer Information Technology
um most of my career from let's say the
age of 30 so after a longer military
service like some of us Israeli do
Israelis do and you know myself in Tech
as well
um I went and started a career in amdocs
around Telecom that's where I got
exposed to a telecom and communication
and you know the we went through back
then the various Wireless
uh launches and changes 2G 3G
smartphones 4G LTE
um Etc
and I saw then I saw a lot of it Go and
the changes that went through the
Telecom industry when I took over radcom
virtualization of network how
you know things that we couldn't fathom
in let's say the beginning of 2000 of
how things can be done by software
it got me really I think excited about
the potential of how you can do real
heavy lifting in Communications
using software and this is already the
second company that we're doing it
um one the first one being radcom which
is still doing it in a very heavy
lifting space and turidian is doing it
for Enterprise communication which you
know in the past used to be still is to
some extent
um
big the industry of routers and lines
and cables that you see in offices
and we took a
very uh disruptive approach
that we can do everything with software
and that this is I'm a software guy and
this got me hooked up Hooked on this of
how you can really disrupt an entire
space
with software and how you know basically
because we're doing it with software you
don't need
mute supply chain you don't need to
produce routers you don't need to go
through what companies needed to to be
in the past of being a you know company
that serves Enterprise customers works
with telcos you need to be a huge
company like a Cisco like you know other
companies that were there before but
huge huge companies today a software
company do need you know it's a little
bit more than being in a garage and you
know a couple of people just creating uh
software you do need some rigor and you
reach some critical mass but
taking that software you can disrupt the
world of communication with the way that
you know the
maturity of software clouds the the
processing power of uh a lot of the
capabilities out there and
very exciting times in my mind
and so if you're looking at where we're
at today
um what do you see you know from and
specifically looking into into your
company today tell me a little bit about
the actual the actual product I imagine
that a lot of the different people here
on you know listening here are probably
not as familiar with it with the space I
certainly am not as familiar as I'd like
to be I'd love to learn a little bit
more about touridion and what actually
you're doing
sure so the way that I would describe Us
in like an elevator picture like a
tagline think of us as a network as a
service okay now networking is to some
extent broad right you can have like
wireless networks you can have wired
networks you have access and you have
your DSL line or your Broadband line at
home you have your broad bed line the
office we took uh we're looking at the
segment of Enterprise connectivity so
when I'm saying Enterprise think let's
think of a big
for the sake of the example automotive
company it has hundreds of sites I don't
know BMW General Motors you know one of
those that has hundreds of sites
worldwide has tens of thousands of
employees worldwide and has Information
Systems has Manufacturing Systems you
need to connect all of these together
you need to connect the sites to the
workloads the software okay you need to
connect people
that are working whether they're working
in the sites or you know today
everybody's like working at least
part-time remote into this entire setup
what we do is we connect
um everything but the access okay so if
you have a big Enterprise each site is
connected to the internet what we're
doing is connecting all the sites
together
okay and making sure that they have high
performance
SLA Telco grades connectivity between
their sites
from the sites to the data centers today
a lot of the data centers are like
virtual data centers in the cloud you
know whether it's just like uh software
like Salesforce or whatever but there's
also other types different clouds and we
connect all of that for a high
performance Network so
when the people of BMW and the sake of
our example log in and connect to their
systems they're getting a consistent
and high performance type of experience
whether it's running a huge backup of
their system or a salesperson is now
quoting something to a customer and you
know the entire
a full spectrum of applications
so think of us as
creating the connections between all
these hundreds of sites
and providing the customer and SLA and
we're doing it
without any physical
transport everything that we're doing is
virtual and you know I can explain that
how that works because that's like the
part of the secret sauce and so right
before we get to there I imagine that
throughout your career you transitioned
you you've had a hand in the
physicalness in the physical world and
then the ver and transitioning also to
the virtual world tell me a little bit
about that transition from your from
your point of view because you know we
you know growing up Generation Z we grow
into a cloud-based world I I learned
that there exists such a thing as
on-prem when I was in the Army right and
and we started fixing that as well but
I've been pretty much on AWS and gcp
since I'm 15. so since did I learned how
to write code so tell me a little bit
about your own experience from your own
eyes
they're treating me a little bit as an
historian with my gray hair I appreciate
it but it's okay
um
a lot of my career was in Information
Technology youth systems okay from
looking at
let's say the years uh
2000 and onward let's let's look at 2005
you know as some sort of uh
a point in time okay you would deploy
there was no Cloud okay you would deploy
applications in a data center okay when
you go into a data center I worked in
ham ducks with a huge data centers so
think of uh the system that does billing
for at T okay it's part of part of my
responsibility
you go and I don't think anybody knows
what it is today when you go through
super domes HP superdomes which were
that weren't that big physically okay
but were huge processing machines
and you need it to have the knowledge to
access those machines
to first of all you know get the machine
installed on the ground okay because
you're running you've ran out of
capacity so customer went and increased
their volume let's say because they were
selling to more subscribers you need
more systems you order servers okay
they'd come somebody needs to connect
them to electricity to uh Communications
wired them and put them in racks and
connect them so there was a lot of data
center activity around that and then you
had the fun of deploying software on it
which you need to install system and
then
various application layers that also
have matured in time you probably don't
know what like middleware is okay there
was a lot of uh how to scale this entire
like web world and online world and
real-time transactions there was a lot a
lot of layers of software that needed to
work together and guess what they didn't
work so well together so as the world
matured part of the simplification that
the big clouds gave us is the ability to
develop software
large-scale software and not deal with
that complexity from the bottom of the
stack almost from the chipset all the
way up to the application layer and
today people just deal with the
application layer and a lot of the
you know below the application there is
abstracted so no way a virtual machines
a container world all that didn't exist
and we needed to find you know solutions
that did similar things and got the
application to scale but it was you know
required hundreds and sometimes
thousands of people to work on it
wow okay so now transitioning back to
the virtualization that you're doing
today
so
um we went so I think just to tie into
what you just touched on yeah you think
that the the world went through a
revolution that like you you said you
grew into it I experienced it of taking
applications to the cloud this was
wasn't uh you know applications that
existed weren't that easy and new
applications maybe you know a lot of
startups created new applications in the
cloud
um but today you can get you know an
entire development
um approach entire a application layer
and of course the scalability that is
required from a cloud and you can take
an application and scale less let's say
scale it infinite indefinitely Or
exponentially or scale it to a huge one
okay and that Revolution today we take
for granted
in Communications
that Revolution didn't exist we need all
the time we're consuming more and more
Communications right we feel it as as
people we usually feel it on the mobile
device but also feel it at home right we
upgraded our internet again and again
and again and everybody's connected to
Wi-Fi and if you look like five six
years ago we weren't streaming that much
today we're consuming everything in
video and streaming we take it also to
the Enterprise world the Enterprises are
consuming more applications a lot of the
stuff is being done in video
excuse me so yeah so the needs are high
and that world has been a physical world
still is a physical world to some extent
you need more communication you call the
telephone company and you ask for a
bigger line you call them again and you
ask for a bigger line today and what we
basically did is when we're dealing with
the connections between in an Enterprise
world and we created our own network
it's a huge virtual Network
we tapped into a
this this is like a huge thing we tapped
not into the three Cloud providers that
everybody knows let's say four or five
that people are very advanced
we tapped into 25 different Cloud
providers and now I'll I'll challenge
you but if you can
quote for me 25 different Cloud
providers quote even 15 then I'm buying
you dinner okay no one knows I I need to
look it up I don't remember them by
heart but tapping into 25 different
providers the Google the Microsoft but
all the way to Oracle IBM the Chinese
ones and local ones
uh local ones that have a global
presence lower tiers give us a full
Global Network where we're taking
software which is basically our routers
and deploying them across all the these
vast data centers
and we're doing all that with automation
so basically a press of a button
the moment that when all of that it's
already deployed then we can manage a
Global Network in almost every location
I would say every location on the planet
that has a data center
and connect businesses you know again we
launch you you can think of other use
cases not businesses but we're focused
now on the Enterprise businesses where
we can serve those Enterprises and
connect all of their needs workloads the
sites the people across those data
centers
and we're using connections that are not
available for the regular public so you
and I you know in general are using
internet connections uh just regular
internet which is free okay we're using
combination of internet connections and
Cloud connections so think of that think
of us that were opening up new tollways
okay that are not open to the public
they are not open to Enterprises the
amount that you have a tall way then you
know you have the experience of a tall
way you pay a little bit okay but no
traffic everything is uh you know moving
at the fast speeds like you'd expect
that's always to do that's basically
what we do uh with very unique
technology and a very unique business
model
amazing wow we're so
you know stun's amazing and sounds like
an amazing journey and we're only we're
only scratching the surface with with
the world that you're in but I'd love to
spend the last minute you know asking
the most important question is as far as
I'm concerned of why I do this show
which is why are you so excited about
what you're doing you know you've
you've been an executive and an amazing
company like amdocs been in different
organizations you were the CEO of a
public company with hundreds of people
why start another company you know why
why are you doing what you're doing why
are you working so hard
um
so I think the the key here is that
the potential of doing a huge disruption
is coupled with mega growth
okay and the pace I'm a fast-paced in
the individual okay I've been around the
block
but uh you know I look at my hobbies
it's mountain biking it's Enduro
motorcycles it's a ski it's uh it's
things that get the adrenaline up and to
get the adrenaline up in Tech you need
something that will be disruptive and
will get to mega growth
okay this has the now the potential of
that mega growth and that's why I'm
spending you know my energy there and
the results
are starting to come in so the
adrenaline is flowing
and then you know that's uh that's like
uh the best feeling in the world because
it gets you you're addicted to it that's
why I do what I do
you want to thank you so much this was
such a fun conversation I really
appreciate it I appreciate your time and
the different things that you've done
and we just scratched the surface but
definitely leaving me more Curious than
we started so thank you very very much
and welcome we enjoyed it it took of
course the best of luck with turidion
okay thanks thanks Micah
thank you
[Music]